you loved her and two broke girls and
the neighborhood now she's got a new
podcast called harmonix that explores
the power of music and sound
let's say a big hello to beth bears
y'all give it up for
[Music]
[Music]
i have a i'm sorry i look like a pirate
it's so
really cool i love it i was like is that
i thought it was like
i was like oh it's part of her outfit
yeah
bad boots no i know honestly i picked
these boots over supposed to be another
one i was like i'm wearing a patch let's
wear ones that match
um so oh it just rhymes look at that um
how are you
cheeks i would pinch poke and oh you
coke but we can't touch each other
because
um but thank you for being here i hear
this is like your first time out
this is my first time out i'm wearing a
bra yeah which is awesome
thank you thanks um
i have on cowboy boots again although
those i've i've kept with me but
yeah i feel excited to be in human
contact with you like just to see your
beautiful faces
well some of you talk to you yes no but
last time i saw you we were folding
shirts we were doing the marie condo
thing because you love her
i love marie kondo i actually i did my
whole house we moved
so i'm very confident i moved recently
did yes
it was something in quarantine huh yeah
i have to move
i'm gonna be honest with you i we did it
well we did too
and everybody was so safe we all got
tested yeah it was it was
think thank the universe but um yeah we
marie condored everything including the
garage which last time i told you
i was gonna say did you get to your
garage yes that seems like a no
okay okay so um we got to it
and it is better than it was but a lot
of it
sparks joy for me and my husband i guess
the garage there's a lot of
orders so i mean especially cowboy boots
um there's
that's my new garage condo oh i like
your chairs
thank you do you want them they're for
sale no you're actually you can have
them for free
you know it's so funny i have a storage
because i moved it to a smaller
place and it's like more charming and
kind of yeah i love it but i was like i
have so much stuff
storage and it didn't spark joy so it's
just like i'm waiting to give it to
someone who needs it
yes but how do you like your new
neighborhood see what we did there
i meet the question we're clever kelly
you're still clever
honey i love you uh yeah it's it's
amazing i mean we
you know we're masked when we go outside
nobody's brought over cookies or
anything because
they can't and we're not able to go say
hi but we we walk dogs there's a lot of
dogs in the neighborhood
everyone in my new neighborhood walks
their dogs and i'm like
am i a jerk i just mine plays in our
backyard
and it's a huge backyard that's probably
like safer in general but
because we're wearing a mask and like at
first i don't know if you've noticed
this but
wearing the mask you're like me i think
like i
smile all the time at everybody and so
when i'm in the new neighborhood you
know i'm trying to be friendly but i
forget i have the mask on
so i'm like smiling you know as big as i
can but all they're saying
are my eyes smiling yeah and then the
people have been like walking quickly
away with their dogs
then i realized guess what you guys i
can just go like this
yeah i can just use my hand okay it's
really funny you said that though
because this is a thing like when i'm in
the car
like i'm southern and everyone waves
like
everyone in your car like when you pass
someone i don't know you wave especially
to write
if they let you buy no one does that
here
no one does that you wave and everyone
looks at you like i don't know you
and i'm just like well you could i can't
it's accidents
we could be friends it's so weird nobody
does we have seriously
so much i know i kelly i just i'm so
happy
whenever we're allowed to hang out we
can talk i know exactly
um so i've always been a brown thumb so
i've never really attempted gardening
but literally the first thing i did when
we went into lockdown was buy a plant
because it just made me feel like if i
can grow
something the world will like repair
itself and we're going to be okay
yes so i've gotten really into it i'm
still a terrible brown thumb with
vegetables
everything has died but flowers
flowers are my jam oh my gosh i love it
they make you so happy it makes me so
happy i even started i started like
getting crafty because what else was
there to do yeah it wasn't working
um and we i started decorating terra
cotta pots and planting plants for like
my neighbors and the postal workers i
sanitized everything don't worry
leaving them outside my door and and
gifting these like plants and it just
therapeutic it's therapeutic for me and
to give it to someone else and go
someone else gets a beautiful flower and
it makes them happy and yeah you're
touching the earth you're connected to
something bigger than ourselves
i agree i mean the new place we moved
into like it's it has like it's
like a secret garden the whole backyard
i didn't have to do anything it's just
there's already like flowers and
everything
it's so great i actually think i brought
you a gift
oh did you i did i want to get that out
here next time but
hey when you say grounding are you weird
like oh you didn't i brought you
i brought you
that's really good it's a whole thing
that i learned on i think it was martha
stewart's website
yeah you tape it and you do a um rubber
band around it however you want it and
then
oh my gosh that's so cool my kids would
love to do that great idea
yeah i'll send you how to do it it's
really easy oh my gosh i'm gonna gift
you one back for yourself
this will be for my house so you and i
talked about anxiety um how have you
managed this during quarantine because
everybody's kind of managed it
differently i've been writing a lot
so that's awesome yeah yeah it's
interesting for me
you know i've always dealt with anxiety
so going into locked
even hypochondriac which is great for a
pandemic when you're a hypochondriac
girl and my old sort of techniques of
like meditation and
and the barns always amazing but it just
i was still having a lot of anxiety if
i'm being honest
and i started listening to music as sort
of when i couldn't drop into meditation
i'd put on a record
started listening to music and just
wanting to listen all the time and i
started thinking about sort of the
relationship between anxiety
mental health and creativity and how
healing is creative
and creativity is healing and then that
led into this new podcast endeavor
about the power of music it's called
harmonics right yeah it's called
harmonics and
so what exactly happens on it so
basically um i
i talked to like glennon doyle who wrote
untamed i
love girl i'm a cheetah
i'm a cheetah i'm a cheese she's the
first episode
oh you can listen and she's incredible
um
and brandi carlisle who did i love that
duet you guys
i've never been more vain i've never
listened to myself more you do have the
best voices of all time
and putting them together i've listened
but i played that video over and over
again i told brandon i'm like a
millionaire
but um i wanted to ask people in the
music industry but also people like
london doyle women
how they handle this time mental health
what's happening in the world the
division in order to bring people
together
promote love and hopefully provide some
sort of healing yeah
and selfishly i get to ask people like
you all the questions i want to know
about what do you do for your mental
health on a day when you don't want to
get out of bed this is an
awesome podcast i would love to have you
on i would love to
you know you should have two another um
glenn and doyle type
figure is brene brown oh i love her her
podcast is amazing yes
ted talks yeah ted talks yeah everything
yeah i would love i have a
i have a dream list this is season one i
have like my dream list but i
really like you know music and an
important feeling i mean and writing is
have you been writing music or i
literally don't know how anybody goes
through anything
horrible bringing their life without
having an outlet like i have with
writing
like even if it doesn't i was telling i
was talking to going the other day on
the voice and i was like
we're both writing right now for our
next albums and it's like even if no one
hears it it's so therapeutic it's so
good for
you just that's your outlet and it's
almost like you know whether you're
religious or not or spiritual whatever
you believe there's something about that
you're giving that gift
of your writing even if nobody ever sees
it and it's a little like marie kondo
too you're letting it go
like thank you for the experience i'm
done yeah yeah totally and
and i'm terrified for this podcast
because i'm usually like the girl
twerking upside down on television and
like falling down the stairs
and
but i realized that like if i expect my
guests to come on and not talk about
you know not just the classic sort of
interview questions if i want them to
get vulnerable and honest then i had to
and so
i i've revealed some stuff and talked
really deeply about my mental health but
then hearing like
that other musicians that i admire have
panic attacks before they go on stage
oh my god especially musicians yeah i'll
talk through it
brandi and i talked about what she's
saying for joni mitchell and how you
know i just
started sweating for her right now wow
but if she can get through that i can
get through you know there's something
about coming together and speaking about
mental health openly which for so long
especially as women were like i can
toughen up you know i can i'm going to
take care of my family i'm going to take
care of everybody around
it's all in that box i know i know uh
so yeah it's been amazingly healing
selfishly for me but also i hope it
helps
other people i cannot wait to be on it
first of all i would love to and also i
can't wait to check it out it sounds
[Music]
amazing